salut aujourd'hui je vous apprendre
quelque chose pour bluffer les gens
votre entourage tout ce que vous voulez
aujourd'hui ou même dans la semaine avec
le sujet qu'attendent tous les mentale
haut depuis début janvier l'hypnose vous
avez promis qu'à partir de la fin de
l'année on commencerait à bordélique noz
et bien c'est fait c'est parti c'est
aujourd'hui mais oui alors tu n'entends
que le son de ma voix et tu peux mettre
un pouce en l'air dans cette vidéo je
vous donne deux trucs pratiques à faire
sur quelqu'un pour bluffer une personne
sans avoir besoin de s'entraîner comme
un ouf avant mais durant les quatre mois
qui restent avant le 31 décembre
on va aborder l'hypnose d'une manière un
petit peu plus profonde est ce que vous
préférez qu'on fasse plusieurs gros
master class des choses de 15 minutes
qui aborde plein de sujets en même temps
et qui vont plus loin où est ce que vous
préférez des vidéos sur ce sujet là plus
souvent donc plus courte mais aussi plus
pratique qui mélange un peu de théorie
et tout de suite un petit peu de
pratique que vous pouvez appliquer vous
mais un sondage juste là où comme ça
vous avez un clic et vous me donnez
votre réponse on va dire que vous avez
jusqu'au 10 septembre pour me donner
votre réponse et après j'étale réa
calendrier en fonction de ça voici pour
vous deux tests de suggestibilité
impossible donc c'est à dire autrement
appelée d induction lorsqu'on fait une
hausse plutôt de spectacle ce sont les
tests qu'ont fait au départ sur un
ensemble de personnes sur un groupe de
personnes pour voir qui est le plus
sensible et qui réagit le mieux mais si
on prenait le temps vraiment de le faire
individuellement ce sont des tests qui
fonctionne quoi qu'il arrive avec tout
le monde
le premier test vous n'avez aucun risque
il est entièrement automatique
évidemment vous avez pas le dire à la
personne à qui vous allez le faire on
appelle cette personne là le sujet voilà
où se peut ce que parce que c'est comme
ça qu'on dit vous demandez donc à votre
sujet de mettre les deux mains comme ça
de les appuyer fortement l'une contre
l'autre et de croiser les doigts comme
ceux ci puis de bien d'y insérer les
demain une fois que c'est fait la
personne de redresser les index comme ça
continue de serrer les demain m'écarter
le plus possible les annexes comme ceci
quand votre spectateurs sujet amis
famille j'en sais rien et dans cette
position est bien en tension vous allez
place et vaudois de part et d'autre des
deux doit donc vous avez les deux doigts
qui sont comme ça et vous avez-vous
vaudois et vos mains qui sont comme ça
et vous et lui expliquer qu'il y ait un
boulon invisible entre ses deux doigts
et que vous allez resserrer la vis pour
faire en sorte qu'elle est 2 doigts se
rapproche de plus en plus de plus en
plus de plus en plus de plus en plus de
plus en plus de plus en plus et ses
doigts vont vraiment se resserrer de
plus en plus de ceux plus en plus de
plus en plus jusqu'à temps qu'ils se
touchent il ya un début de suggestions
dedans évidemment mais aussi une partie
physiologique qui fait qu
automatiquement les doigts ne peuvent
pas rester dans cette position
si tout le reste est bien resserré bien
en tension ils vont avoir cette tendance
naturelle à se relâcher à se rapprocher
on ne garde jamais un muscle en tension
indéfiniment et ça c'est ce qui va vous
servir asseoir votre qualité
d'hypnotiseur du moment car oui
forcément quand vous faites un test
comme ça quand vous faites une induction
comme ça vous devez avoir un discours
très cohérent et donner le sentiment que
vous êtes très confiant en ce que vous
faites et que c'est pas ça va marcher
c'est ça fonctionne y'a pas il n'y a pas
d'autre solution donc mes techniques
comme ça tu vas voir c'est une hypnose
simple quelque chose de léger quelque
chose de plus d'omar en croise bien les
doigts sert bien complètement mettez
deux doigts comme ça toujours en tension
et regarde si je place mes doigts comme
ça sans que tu puisse rien faire je vais
retirer une vis imaginaire qui passe
entre tes deux doigts les deux doigts
vont commencer à se rapprocher de plus
en plus rentrer dans le personnage de
l'hypnotiseur à ce moment là un autre
test de suggestibilité qui fonctionne
bien vous demandez à une personne de se
mettre devant vous mais doha vous vous
lui demandez fermer les yeux et vous
mettez les mains sur ses épaules et vous
désorienté un petit peu mais gentiment
rend très légèrement un tout petit peu
en lui demandant de toujours avoir les
yeux fermés donc d'avoir confiance en
vous vous placez vos deux mains sur ses
omoplates pour qu'elles ressentent bien
et le tactile est aussi la chaleur de
vos mains et vous lui expliquez que vos
fermes mesures que vous allez décoller
les mains alors elle va se sentira tirés
en arrière elle doit garder les yeux
fermés tout le long et vous faire
confiance vous décollez lentement les
mains mais le plus lentement possible
plus lentement possible plus lentement
possible et en répétant cette phrase de
suggestions de tu te sens attire en
arrière tu te sens attiré par mes mains
il ya comme un magnétisme entre mes
mains et ton dos comme une aimantation
et ton dos est attiré par mes mains et
vous prenez vraiment le temps de faire
ça le fait qu'elle est en plus les yeux
fermés et qu'elle est encore la
sensation au fait de du toucher de vos
mains sur ses omoplates de l'attirer
légèrement en arrière plus de plus en
plus rapidement évidemment mettez-vous
en position de la retenir parce que
sinon elle tombe
et ça ce serait dommage voilà pour ces
deux petites un diction du dimanche qui
va vous permettre de bluffer peut-être
votre famille dès ce soir n'hésitez pas
à vous entraîner un petit peu quand je
dis à vous entraîner c'est à parler tout
seul de ce que vous allez leur dire peut
être comme s'il y avait quelqu'un devant
vous et entraînez vous à tous que vous
allez lui dire pour ne pas vous
retrouver sec en train d'essayer comme
ça pour les premières fois et répondez
au sondage pour que je sache quelle
forme avoue préférer pour qu'on continue
de parler un petit peu cheap noces dans
le sondage et puis bien sûr dans les
commentaires et même les autres sujets
que vous aimeriez que j'aborde d'ici à
la fin de l'année je suis en train de
prévoir toutes les vidéos toutes les
vidéos je m'entends un jeu
c'est juste mes thèmes et sujets comme
on faisait depuis le début de l'année
avec le cahier comme ça je sais que dans
cette vidéo j'aurai plein de
propositions de sujets que vous aimeriez
j'adore n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
avant de partir puisque le mental boxe
et une vidéo par jour pendant un an
depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31
décembre
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao